No,
I have said it on many occasions.
I said, look,
the Galicians and Galicians
you gained a lot when Feijó left Galicia.
But we lost all the Spanish ones,
huh?
Because of course,
suddenly
we have heard about it
and we have heard the head of the opposition
say
to be back in the Mediterranean
and that Badajoz is in Catalonia,
bad in bad in geography for mr.
feijo.
He has also gone so far as to say that
that the sun dilates the pupils.
Bad in biology.
Mr. Feijo
said the Spanish economy was going into recession
and last year we grew at 2.5%.
and this year we will continue to lead the European economy.
Bad economics,
Mr. Weaver.
And this week
we have seen how they have confused Mr.
feijo
methane with methanol.
Bad at organic chemistry,
Mr. Feijo.
But effectively,
Spain does not need,
it does not deserve
1 opposition that is based on methanol,
which is colorless,
and toxic.
Needs and deserves 1 useful opposition